she lived deep in the forest in a tiny
cottage and sold herb or Emma DS for a
living people living in the town nearby
called her Bloody Mary and said she was
a witch none dare to cross the old crone
for fear that their cows would go dry
their food stores would rot away before
winter their children would become sick
or any other number of terrifying things
that an angry witch could do to her
neighbors then the little girls began to
disappear one by one no one could find
out where they had gone grief-stricken
family searched the woods the local
buildings and the house and barns but
there was no sign of the missing girls
a few brave souls even went to Bloody
Mary's home in the woods to see if the
witch had taken their girls but she
denied any knowledge of their
disappearances they had noticed that
Mary's Haggard appearance had changed
she looked younger more attractive the
neighbors are suspicious but they could
find no proof that the witch had taken
their children then came the night when
the daughter of the Miller rose from her
bed and walked outside following an
enchanted sound that no one else could
hear the Millers wife had a toothache
and was sitting up in the kitchen treat
in her tooth with a herbal remedy when
she saw her daughter leave the house she
screamed for her husband and followed
the girl the Miller came running and
together they tried to restrain the girl
but she kept breaking free heading into
the forest the desperate cries of the
Miller and his wife woke the neighbors
they came to assist the frantic couple
when suddenly a sharp eyed farmer gave a
shout and pointed towards a strange
light at the edge of the woods a few
townsman followed him into the field and
saw Bloody Mary stand and besides a
large oak tree holding a magic wand that
was pointed at the Millers house she was
glowing on an earthly light as she set
her evil spell upon the miller's
daughter
the townsmen grabbed their guns in their
pitchforks and they ran towards the
witch when she heard the commotion
Bloody Mary broke off her spell and fled
back into the woods
the farsighted farmer had loaded his gun
with silver bullets in case the witch
ever came after his daughter the farmer
took aim and fired the bullet hit buddy
Mary in the hip and she fell to the
ground the angry townsman left upon her
and carried her back into the field
where they built a huge bonfire and
burned her at the stake as she burned
Bloody Mary screamed they curse at the
villagers if anyone mentioned her name
aloud before a mirror she would send her
spirit to avenge her terrible death when
she was finally dead the villagers went
back to Mary's house and they found the
unmarked graves of their little girls
she had used their blood to make herself
young again from that day on anyone
foolish enough to chant Bloody Mary's
name three times before a darkened
mirror would summon the vengeful spirit
of the witch it is said that she will
tear their bodies to pieces and rip
their souls from their mutilated bodies
the souls of these unfortunate ones will
burn in torment as Bloody Mary once
burned and they will be trapped in the
mirror forever
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you
if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explains